[Music]
this
was my last gig if that has happened by
now it's like a miracle
miracles happen
[Music]
what happened electricity flicked off
all over the world
yesterday ellie bought you a present all
my troubles seemed so
far away now it looks as though they're
here to stay
oh i believe in yesterday
when did you write that i didn't write
it paul mccartney wrote it the beatles
who
john paul george and ringo the beatles
no stop it yesterday it's one of the
greatest songs ever written
well it's not coldplay it's not fix you
[Music]
do you genuinely not know who the
beatles are genuinely
[Music]
sorry i'm just listening to jack's new
song what's this one called leave it be
let it be
well rock on jack
[Music]
hi we should talk see we pay and you
write songs
and then you make a ton of money and
then we take most of it
we would like you to write something
right now
something in the way she moves
no one's ever written this many great
songs how'd you do it
attracts me like no other lover
sometimes it feels like someone else has
written all the songs
i've been waiting half my life for you
to wake up and love me
but i'm a school teacher and you are the
world's greatest singer songwriter i'm
not except for you
are
[Music]
it's gonna be the greatest album of all
time i've got two men who claim that the
songs are theirs
let's see how this plays out shall we
[Applause]
listen up please make some noise for mr
jack
let me just give you this advice song
title hey
dude hey dude are you sure
hey dude that's so much better
[Music]
bye